so let's talk a little bit about
charitable giving and this one is close
to my heart because I run a non-profit
so why do folks donate to charity well
you might have your own motivations for
most folks I think it just feels good
they might feel that they have certain
privileges in life that other folks
don't have or they might want to see a
disease cured help educate folks help
the world in some way and if you haven't
tried it I encourage you to when you
donate money or you donate some of your
time services or you donate Goods to a
charity and you feel like hey I'm making
the world a little bit better it feels
really good now some people might be a
little cynical and say oh well they get
a tax write-off whenever they donate
money Etc but I want to be very clear
because I've heard that a lot whenever
someone has seen someone else donate oh
well they're just getting a tax
write-off
in the vast majority of cases you do not
get more money back than you donate in
most most cases if you say donate a
hundred dollars that's just going to
reduce your income by a hundred dollars
and let's say your marginal tax rate is
30 to make the math easy that means
it'll reduce your taxes by 30 percent of
that hundred dollars so if you donate a
hundred dollars to a not-for-profit to a
charity you will get thirty dollars back
in that situation on your taxes but you
still donated a net seventy dollars so
when folks are donating don't be cynical
about it they're definitely giving more
than they're receiving there are some
special cases maybe you have a car that
you couldn't sell for more than a few
hundred dollars and if you donate to a
charity you might be able to have a
slightly larger write-off than that but
in the great majority of cases uh folks
are giving more than they're receiving
and what they're really receiving is
that feeling that they're doing good for
the world